when 60s radical Steve DeAngelo wasn't
helping nominate a pig for president at
the 1968 Democratic National Convention
he was turning the trials of Vietnam
protesters into kangaroo courts while
this former yippie still rocks the same
hairstyle now he's in business selling
medical marijuana for many years I've
dreamed of creating an environment that
was really worthy of this magnificent
almost magic planted it is D'Angelo's
dream was fulfilled in 2006 when he
opened the world's largest dispensary
Harborside Health Center located in
Oakland California it distributes 25
million dollars of medical marijuana per
year to nearly 200,000 patients all out
in the open all with the blessing of
both the state of California and the
City of Oakland the US Justice
Department takes an about-face on
medical marijuana in California after
first saying they would respect
dispensaries that operate under state
law now comes a crackdown Melinda Hague
is the US Attorney for the Northern
District of California and in October of
2011 she and the three other US
attorneys in California announced a
campaign to close California's medical
cannabis dispensaries and in July of
2012 a civil forfeiture notice was taped
to our front door and we were shocked
because our model has always been about
legal compliance and responsibilities
while Hague has declined to comment on
herbicides case she spoke about the
crackdown at a Justice Department press
conference in October of 2011 the law
has been hijacked by profit ears
marijuana cultivation is supposed to be
not for profit the City of Oakland
examines our financials every single
year to verify that we're operating in
non-profit compliers
these places are prime targets for
robberies and violence if you take a
look at the incidence of crime in our
neighborhood prior to the opening harbor
site and after the opening you see a
reduction there's a reason for the
security guards and fences we don't use
bulletproof glass or a barbed wire or
armed guards there's not a weapon
anywhere on the Harborside premises we
don't need retail marijuana out
across the street from playgrounds and
schools where far more than one thousand
feet away from any sensitive site when
it comes to Harborside for Melinda Hague
it's size that matters
somehow she argued simply because we had
so many patients that it would be more
likely that people would be breaking the
law she never really explained that
theory while it's no secret that some
medical marijuana dispensaries mainly
cater to recreational users Harborside
takes its mandate of helping sick people
very seriously
we started steep hill laboratory and
became the first dispensary anywhere in
the world to laboratory test all of the
medicine is provided to our patients
nobody really you know including US
Attorney Melinda Hague has ever made any
allegation that Harborside has violated
California laws regarding cannabis
nobody
and then the raids came while Harborside
managed to avoid the SWAT teams the city
of Oakland became increasingly worried
as it saw the crackdown extend even to
the most compliant kind of businesses
what would happen if all the law-abiding
dispensaries were shuttered it would
create up a public health and safety
crisis in the city of Oakland so Oakland
decided to fight the feds - arguing in
court that it should be able to join
Harbor sides case but if you thought
Hague would change her tactics after a
major u.s. city sided with a pot shop to
sue the federal government - think again
under the government's perspective you
can't do anything city and citizens or
just Ottawa
attorney Cedric Chow is representing the
city pro bono to me this is not the
Soviet Union this is the United States
of America when Oakland issued us
permits the black market in Oakland for
marijuana dropped these patients are not
going to just stop you know saying okay
that's great I'm gonna go back to my
pain they're gonna go on the streets we
will never abandon our patients even in
Congress outrage was building with rep
Sam Farr and Dana Rohrabacher leading
the charge to stop the Justice
Department and stick up for doctors and
patients some people are suffering and
if a doctor feels that he needs to
prescribe something to alleviate that
suffering it is
moral for this government to get in the
way so last December and then again in
May of 2015
Congress voted to borrow the Justice
Department from using federal tax money
to prosecute Harborside or any other
dispensaries considered legal under
state law in fact I don't even know how
the the judge Department lawyer flew out
to argue the case in the Ninth Circuit
if he was using taxpayer funds because
that's contrary to law even the three
other US attorneys in California dropped
their remaining cases to close
dispensaries after Congress acted so why
is it that only Melinda Hague soldiers
on with hers the judges asked a lawyer
from the Justice Department great
pointedly they said why why is the
Justice Department picking this fight I
think that's a good exact quote the
Justice Department is looking the other
way in all these other states why is it
continuing to do this as to Harborside
and justify Malloy so I don't know so he
doesn't know I don't know so it's not
clear if Hague has just gone rogue or if
the DOJ or Obama ever really intended to
follow through on their repeated
declarations the Department of Justice
has made clear going back to 2009 to the
present that we would not exercise
federal resources to to those who've got
by by state law some made over ten years
ago what I'm not gonna be doing is using
Justice Department resources to try to
circumvent state laws on this issue the
federal government is whether you want
to call it hypocritical schizophrenic
they they really you know it's confused
it's confused on the day we arrived at
Harborside D'Angelo had just received a
letter from Congress criticizing the
Department of Justice for its conduct
what that letter means for me basically
is that says that Melinda Hague is a
criminal she's the one who needs to be
stopped not Harborside
but still a hippie at heart Steve
DeAngelo refuses to shy from the
prospect of another show trial
so if Melinda Hague really wants to try
and convince 12 people from the Bay Area
that Harborside Health Center is more of
a harm than a benefit to the community
I'm ready to take her on that